Traductor: Paula Motter
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Cerca nuestro,
algún animal está defecando.
De hecho, el reino animal produce
a diario una cantidad de estiércol
equiparable al caudal de agua
que cae de las cataratas Victoria.
¿Cómo es posible entonces que el planeta
no estuviera cubierto de excremento?
Se lo debemos agradecer
al humilde escarabajo pelotero
por alimentarse del excedente.
Capaces de enterrar en una misma noche
un volumen 250 veces más pesado
que su propio cuerpo,
estos denodados insectos
trabajan muy de prisa
para formar una interminable
cantidad de heces.
Más de 7000 especies conocidas
de escarabajos estercoleros
hacen una labor de limpieza profunda
en cinco continentes,
excepto en la Antártida.
La primera tarea de estos escarabajos
es localizar el estiércol.
Algunos viven en la zona anal
de animales más grandes,
listos para salir
cuando esos animales defecan.
Otros detectan con el olfato las heces
que los animales dejan en el camino.
El excremento de un elefante
puede atraer en 15 minutos
4000 escarabajos estercoleros.
Por eso, en cuanto uno de ellos
encuentra el excremento,
debe trabajar muy de prisa
para apropiarse del botín.
La mayoría de las especies
se dividen en tres grupos principales:
peloteros,
cavadores
y moradores.
Los peloteros forman
una pelota de estiércol,
y con las patas traseras
la transportan rodando
a un sitio alejado de los competidores.
Parejas potenciales
se abalanzan sobre la pelota,
y en cuanto el dueño de la pelota
elige su pareja,
ambos entierran esa pelota en el suelo.
Cuando la pelota está bajo tierra,
la hembra pone un huevo allí dentro.
Los cavadores proceden de otra manera.
Cuando excavan debajo de una deposición,
algunos arrastran excremento
dentro del suelo, lo compactan
y moldean distintas masas
llamadas "masas nido",
pelotas de estiércol,
o "salchichas" de estiércol,
según sea su forma y tamaño.
Los cavadores machos hacen
un espectacular despliegue de cuernos
para disputar con otros machos
el dominio de los túneles,
que defienden hasta que la hembra
haya puesto su huevo.
Algunos cavadores machos evitan la lucha
haciéndose pasar por hembras sin cuernos
y de este modo entran
sigilosamente a los túneles
para aparearse mientras
los guardianes están distraídos.
El tercer grupo está formado
por los moradores,
que tienen un método más directo
al desovar dentro del mismo excremento.
De este modo, las crías quedan
más expuestas a la depredación
a diferencia de las crías
de peloteros y cavadores.
A medida que las larvas se alimentan,
cavan numerosos túneles en el estiércol
y dejan restos que son rápidamente
colonizados por bacterias y hongos
y que luego desaparecen con la erosión.
Una vez que las larvas nacen,
ya sea dentro de un túnel,
una pelota o un excremento,
consumen el estiércol hasta llegar
a pupa por el proceso de metamorfosis
y luego se convierten
en escarabajos adultos.
Además de limpiar el estiércol,
el trabajo de estos insectos
tiene una gran importancia ecológica.
En primer lugar, son agentes secundarios
para dispersar semillas.
El excremento de los monos,
jabalíes y otros animales
está repleto de las semillas
que comen a través de las frutas.
Cuando los escarabajos entierran
sus pelotas de excremento,
involuntariamente protegen
esas semillas de los predadores,
propiciando sus posibilidades
de germinación.
Para aprovechar semejante ventaja,
una planta sudafricana
ha evolucionado para producir semillas
cuyo aspecto y olor son muy parecidos
al estiércol de un animal,
confundiendo así al escarabajo
que, engañando, las entierra.
Los escarabajos estercoleros
también cumplen un importante papel
en los sistemas agrícolas.
El ganado bovino y ovino, por ejemplo,
produce una gran cantidad de excremento
que contiene nutrientes
beneficiosos para las plantas.
Los escarabajos desarman el excremento
y lo entierran en túneles profundos
dentro del suelo,
facilitando a las raíces de las plantas
el acceso a esos nutrientes.
El trabajo de estos insectos
en beneficio de los agricultores
se ha estimado en un valor anual
de USD 380 millones en EE.UU.
y de GBP 367 millones en el Reino Unido.
Estos escarabajos también pueden ayudar
a combatir el calentamiento global,
pues reducen la emisión
de gases de efecto invernadero
asociada a la agricultura.
Los microbios que se desarrollan
en estiércol con bajo contenido de oxígeno
producen metano, un potente gas
de efecto invernadero.
Pero los escarabajos oxigenan el estiércol
cuando excavan túneles en su interior,
impidiendo que los microbios
produzcan metano.
El escarabajo estercolero
esparce las semillas,
colabora con los agricultores
y combate el cambio climático;
y todo, con solo hacer su tarea.
La próxima vez que te topes con estiércol
en el bosque o en el campo,
quizá sientas la tentación
de observarlo más de cerca.